[Music]
you're giving us more this this isn't
fair we're just offense it's going to be
scared caught punches touchdown this
really can be a great great offense and
it's all because andrew luck is back to
who he was wide open was eric
they have the best offensive line in
football the colts are dominating the
game in every facet horseshoe is back
baby the horseshoe is fast
yeah
they they keep working our comments in
here you know we've probably said enough
this offseason they could just cobble
together things we've already said and
fill up the three hours a day pretty
much they don't need us any i should
probably stop talking
just
just uh just take little splices of
things we've said and just string it all
together and there's a show well
it's uh they constantly give us positive
things to talk about and make smart and
i'm talking about big picture no i know
for every team well trying to change the
stuff well no i thought you were i was i
just had a cold season i had i just had
a programming thought right if they
wanted to get rid of us yes we have said
enough that they could just take little
snippets of our voice and just put three
hours away it wouldn't be good the
fodder and all the things i say in
between is where i make my money that's
what makes it fun they don't want to
hear a chopped up version of that stuff
all right the cults the cults are making
their money because they they
overachieved remember we had chris
ballard the jam of the colts with us
yeah i think it was the scouting combine
of the league meetings in 2018
how long is it going to take to turn
this around he said two drafts well it
took one draft yeah especially when you
get two all pros in one draft in the
first two rounds and darius leonard and
quentin nelson but you know this year a
ton of cap space they didn't give in to
the temptation to go after a le'veon
bell i don't think they needed to i
think they were smart about what they
did people were surprised by how much
they gave devin functions a receiver who
underachieved with carolina maybe with
andrew luck he'll be a lot better they
got justin houston for a bargain deal
and i you know i think there's a reason
to be very optimistic about the colts
right now i'd say they're the favorite
to win the division i i mean it's a
incredible division but the colts yes i
mean hey frank reich got a lot of
respect for him
uh and of course chris ballard is one of
the best gm's in football what he's done
with that roster in that short period of
time and you know a bunch of guys i want
to say value signings value draft picks
guys that are maybe under the radar for
the common fan to a degree but he goes
oh well this guy i can draft in the
third or third round is every bit as as
good as the guy being drafted at the end
of the first round so i'll wait for him
there and you know not give up too many
assets but hey funches i think was a
great signing for them they don't have a
big receiver so that gives them another
guy down in the red zone that luck can
throw you know jump balls to 50 50 balls
other than eric ebron so teams can't
just focus on that all the time you know
getting a justin houston i would look at
their team and go that was one area of
need certainly maybe another true threat
off the edge but uh gosh you evaluate
their roster it's the one of the best
o-lines in football the d-line might not
have a lot of like household names but a
lot of young and up-and-comers guys that
i watch in the draft process that i go
oh i really like that kid you know the
muhammad kid number 97 kamika komoko
turay uh who they drafted out of rutgers
last year uh jabal sheard's on the list
re-signing marcus hunt so they've really
done a good job
throughout the roster of acquiring depth
and of course having talent at all those
positions as well 10 draft picks this
year as well and you look at what chris
balot has done so far you know i'm not
ready to call him the best gm in
football he was my choice for executive
of the year you went with ryan pace the
bears gm right but yeah i i think you
got to get a pellet on the horse or pelt
on the wall as the case may be to be
considered the best yemen but he's up
there and and i think one of the things
the colts are struggling with is
when they had peyton manning and all the
star players around him they were a team
that we could count on for 12 or 13 wins
every year and they're not back to that
level so we don't view them now isn't it
weird yeah we don't view them as like
they were 10 to 15 years ago even though
they are in position to be highly
competitive this year yeah i think the
probably part of the reason we're not
doing that is because we had a
you know a time period without andrew
luck to where they kind of got off our
radar there for a little bit but they
certainly seem like they're set up for
the long haul here uh and they are
they're a talented football team but you
know to what we were saying yeah maybe
i'd give them the edge in the division
but man it's not by a lot the afc south
is real this year i mean how would you
rank the four right now oh wow i know
how i would do it you know how you do it
right off the bat it's jaguars texans
titans um i'd probably go the same way i
think i'm with you there i'm gonna give
the jags the slight edge over the texans
there even though that's not easy i mean
the texans did you know uh win the
division and and of course the jags have
new new pieces there but uh highly
competitive would not be shocked that
two teams again make the afc playoffs
out of this division but the fact that
we put the titans at four yeah i keep
going back to week one i'm
way too early upset special one titans
over browns yeah i can feel it i can
already feel it somewhere in the
stratosphere well yeah the titans are
continually being disrespected and the
browns everybody's telling them how
great they are so it does seem from that
man this is gonna be one of
yes oh my god we didn't see this coming
well maybe we should have right there's
you know after you do this long enough
and you have that feeling you start
thinking you know what it would be nice
to see it coming once in a while i see
that coming watch the brown's gonna win
38 to 10. but the cults i think will win
that division barring some sort of an
injury and that's that's the one thing
that will change all of this
injuries will happen we just don't know
who they're gonna happen to we don't
know when they're gonna happen we don't
know how long they're gonna be out but
injuries will reconfigure everything if
they would lose andrew luck that changes
everything yeah if the titans
are not the titans but if the jaguars
would lose nick foles that was change
everything right but but for now i think
the colts are the class of the division
they built the wall so they're protected
it's a big wall okay it is yes i mean
their o-line is special andrew luck
certainly seemed like he got his groove
back frank reich is so creative on that
side of the ball
i have one question about their team
only one really roster question where i
go oh i just don't love this position on
their football team and i think we saw
it kind of you know show itself in the
afc divisional game against the chiefs i
don't think they have enough corners who
can play man-to-man in big situations
against the big the better offenses in
football too many times in that game in
the afc championship is third down it
was second down they're playing zone
what happened we saw mahomes move in the
pocket find a little hole in the zone
zoom sidearm first down oh you know
there's travis kelsey sitting in a hole
boom you know to me the good teams in
the nfl you got to be able to play
man-to-man in some certain situations so
guys like patrick mahomes you just don't
make it that easy on them that's why we
saw new england have success against
them that would be my one little issue
with the colts roster that was one of
the questions bill belichick the
patriots coach raised in the offseason
where are we going to find all these
larger corners to cover all these big
receipts and then he drafts a huge
corner joe joanne williams and because
that's where his mind was he's going how
am i going to cover the devon functions
of the world how am i going to cover
eric ebron when he's in the red zone so
yeah he's thinking ahead but uh yeah you
got to have that ability to me and third
and four or less in the nfl with
offenses as creative as they are
quarterbacks as good as they are
receivers as good as they are catching
and reading coverages
you just can't play zone against that
anymore you got to have a guy that can
go i'm going to make life really hard on
the quarterback and receiver to make
this four yard completion really tight
and hairy and you want to try to jam it
in there good luck but i might get a
hand and it pops up and it's
interception so
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports